感觉我这辈子也没做过什么伤天害理的事儿，
也没做过什么坑蒙拐骗的事儿，
所以我就应该平平安安活到老，
就是我给自己的心理暗示。
再有一个就是不管怎么样，
就是我拿到这个剧本的话，
只要我能平平安安活到老，
就没有人敢欺负我的孩子，
无论面对什么样的困难，
无论面对什么样的这个风险，
无论面对什么样的坎坷，
我一定能挺过去，
或者是23年，
他丢我以后，
原因跟大家都差不多，
就外面有人了，
那个时候就挺痛苦的，
我就一直钻进直播间去，
那孩子学了一些东西，
拿到了大部分的财产和孩子的抚养权，
离婚以后有三个月吧，
他就跟外地了，
那个尿呆了，
尿呆以后他就回来了，
就给了我一笔钱，
大概有十几个吧，
我觉得既然他回来了，
也给钱了，
孩子也需要付钱给你回来吧，
但是我们到现在也没有进争，
他每个月能给我大概两个，
就是抚养费，
最近我突然刷到一个视频，
就有一个人他突然去世了，
但是他没有子女，
他的财产就归国家接管了，
还没有钱给他，
对然安葬费这样的就突然害怕了，
因为我现在单身，
我一个人在一个城市，
我一边上班一边带孩子，
我的小孩现在11岁，
假如说有个天灾人祸，
我突然走了，
我怎么去保证说我的小孩能拿到我全部的财产，
通过什么样的法律手段，
我是立遗嘱啊，
还是去公证？
就是干嘛的，
把我所有财产都得为了我的小孩，
有这个担忧是很正常的，
尤其是刷到这样的新闻了之后啊，
像你的这个情况，
第一没有结婚证，
第二我不知道你父母是否健在，
从父母健在，
我一个人在一个陌生的城市，
虽然我们在一个省，
但是不在一个地方，
而在这个城市里，
我们没有亲戚，
只有一个人住，
我的话，
他们在城里边有一套房，
大概有七八十万吧，
他们现在回农村了，
农村呢，
也有两层小楼足够了，
自己住俗了，
城里的房子就租出去了，
但是他们可能说小的，
说以后留给箱子了。
从法律上来说的话，
你确实是可以立遗嘱，
白纸黑字写下来，
你去世之后，
你名下的所有的财产，
包括动产、
不动产可以列一个清单，
存款也可列一个清单，
由你的孩子个人单独继承，
这样的话就可以排除你父母的继承资格，
但是因为你的孩子呢，
现在还小，
他才11岁，
自己是没有办法掌控这些财产的，
那么我们就要讲到遗嘱里面有一个财产管理人的这样一个角色，
比如说你有什么特别信得过的朋友啊，
特别信得过的亲人啊，
日子过得比你好的，
我其实考虑到了，
我就是想咨询一下，
我就是智能财产管理的人，
那我有两个人，
一个呢是我姐，
我姐姐比我大两岁，
他这个人吧，
就是情绪超级有。
而且格局很大的一个，
包括我当时在这个财产纠纷离婚的时候，
他起到了很大的作用，
就是我拿到了大部分的财产，
养女如母嘛，
因为我们家情况比较特殊，
我爸爸我高中的时候他就出车祸，
有残疾了，
所以等于是我姐自己一个人看起了我一个家，
我姐姐还有弟弟都是我姐在扛，
他现在家庭条件，
然后跟我们家差不多，
就是房子啊，
车子啊，
存款啊这些都有，
他有可能离死之后，
他在分分钟找下一个，
分分钟再生个孩子，
就是难免会有人性风险吧，
他这个人吧，
说实话人品不是很快，
如果特别坏的话，
拿不到这么多财产，
每个月两个，
其实等于是他2/3都给我了，
你分开以后每几个月他就出国了，
给年的话，
半年回来两个月还是跟我们住一起的，
这种像你的这个情况的话，
可以分散风险，
一部分财产由你的姐姐来代管，
一部分财产由你的前夫来代管，
但是我不是很相信她，
她什么都好，
但是她好像我以为你刚能是想要说服我，
她人品还不错呢，
因为我上来就跟你说，
他有可能结婚再生孩子啊，
什么都好，
就比如说孝顺啊，
这个工作干的也很好呀，
人也很善良，
这好色，
这一点真的是挺无语的，
你看这孩子不错啊，
对我呢，
全方面特别大方。
有个特别重要什的财产构成啊，
有房子，
有车子，
还有存款，
黄金银首饰这种大概有几百克，
支付宝里边有一点基金，
还有一点股票，
我是想问一，
假如说我自己这个遗嘱软件里的东西啊，
你怎么去写名啊，
别人怎么知道我密码什么的，
还是说提前把这个账号密码什么的都交给我姐，
然括保险柜的密码，
别人是很难搞到密码的，
就算你做了这个公证遗嘱，
你说把你支付宝里面的钱给谁，
如果说没有你的密码，
真正要去取这笔钱的话，
也是要几经波折的，
那我就贴支付宝除来都是扫脸了，
有的是短信验证，
那这样的话就是我现在列个清单，
就我财产清单有什么密码，
这些东西是不能放在那个公证遗嘱里的，
你公证遗遗嘱里面啊，
只能写明白你的财产清单，
比如你的房产证编号，
具体的位置，
比如你股票的账号，
账号下的金额，
这个是可以写明白的，
但是密码是不可以写在公证遗嘱里面的，
5年岁之前我也不，
我想找两后找妈妈的事，
我在想我这个财产要不要分一点钱，
是我妈妈，
如果我分给我爸爸妈妈的话，
那我弟弟是姐姐都有继承权，
对吧，
假如说他们有一天不在了。
还是要去继续去搜这个，
我觉得这个东西啊，
你可以口头的跟你的姐姐做一个嘱咐，
就是假设我要做这个事情的话，
我可能不会在遗嘱里面说给我爸妈多少钱，
那我会给我信任的这个人说我这个就叫君子协定了，
就在我爸妈出现什么情况的时候，
你可以在多少钱范围之内自由决定，
那如果说我的孩子以后要交给我姐姐的话，
那这个学费啊，
生活费啊，
是怎么去约定，
这些所有的钱都应该从你的产里面去支出，
要开销的学费生活费都应该是从你的遗产里面去支出的，
而且如果你的姐姐这个人啊，
呃，
如你所言，
人品端方方面能力也还行的话，
他也会拿你的这个财产去做一个定存呀，
对，
有的钱他他可能存，
这个不需要约定，
本就该如此，
本就该由你遗产来支付他的学费，
生活费，
假如说是哪一天我过是了这个房产证，
还有这个车子是怎么处理啊，
直接过户到我孩子名下了，
还是车子就个变卖变现，
然后存在了车祸那样其实都可以选择，
作为遗产的管理人的话，
他都可以去做这个抉择的，
你也可以约定未必一定要说过户到孩子的名下，
因为孩子需要，
他需要的是钱，
他需要的不是。
的车子不是房子，
我还担心一个是因为我之前在哪里听说过不要早早的把房产过户给未成年孩子，
因为你不确定他这个监护人，
就是说这个孩子的位置，
不一定有好的那个想法或者说什么的，
因为孩子的房产是不是跟父亲也有一点关系，
他是道德风险，
如果说孩子的父亲是属于那种又不能挣钱，
又非常无赖，
又没有底线，
又没有亲情观念的人的话，
她确实存在一定的道德风险，
这孩子没了的话，
父亲是可以法定继承的，
但是以你现在描述的话，
你的前夫到不存在这样的风险，
首先人家自己是能挣钱的，
人家不属于你，
人性卑劣到那种程度，
人家不属于，
那就不用考虑这个因素了，
我的那些手势到时候直接就交给我姐处理是吗？
还是说变现，
因为金价在周口的长了，
这个东西是直接就是还留存着，
等到孩子长大以后，
成年以后给他，
还是说变现，
我不是专业的人啊，
因为金价我是不可预知的，
我不知道等孩子20岁之后，
这个金价是不是又翻了很多番了，
所以我觉得这件事情你也别操心了，
就留给你姐来决定，
他都卖了两三百四了，
四五百块钱都卖，
我千万不要卖，
既然这样的咱。
你也就别想那个了，
就留给孩子做个念想，
甚不至人性是这样的，
既然你是让你姐要担这么大的干系，
做这么大的这样一个事儿，
我觉得给你姐留一点也是一个心意，
嗯，
行，
这个遗嘱啊，
我是不是得找个公证处去公证，
你要不要找律师也可以，
那需不需要说录一个视频的，
问一下公证处做公证遗嘱都必须要有录视频的，
你想跟孩子说的话，
或者说怎么怎么样的话，
咱就是说在这个过程当中也可以的，
现在就是我在给你说这个一该是文件形式，
对，
一个是视频形式，
形式都行，
就是我期我不太懂我这的，
不能说他会不会说倒闭啊，
找不到这个地方了，
就算出现这样的情况，
这只要是他是依法成立的公证处，
具有公证资质，
就算有一天这个公证处不在了，
但是这个公证处在他依法具有公证资质的过程当中，
做出来的公证书依然是受到法律堡的这材料录的这个视频啊，
还有这个文件，
就是你们在公证处还是说我自己提示好多份，
公证处会留一份备案，
你自己会有一份正版，
同时的话，
你可以要求很多的副本，
可取一个例子啊，
假设做一份遗嘱，
假设收费是1000块钱，
那么他可能副本的话你加10块钱。
加20块钱，
他给你若干个副本，
副本和正本具有同样的法律效力，
那我就可以说把这个副本交给我信任的人，
可以说我五件对，
好嘞，
别的倒是没有什么事情了，
因为下天的话可能就是一点点关于说我跟孩子他爸爸的事，
现在的话就是他在国外嘛，
马上要过年要回来了，
其实从心里来讲我对他有感情，
但是我从来没想过说跟他复婚，
从小过说要给他再生小孩，
最近他一直说要不要再生个小孩啊，
所以我是不敢的，
我也不想领证，
现在的话生活的很好，
我不知道我决定的对不对，
我现在我自己有工作的，
我太爱缺钱，
不是那么富有，
但是足够我和孩子生活了，
不过因为上大学的钱也是有的，
最近总是说要再生一个女孩儿，
因为我们家是男孩，
要求我陪她回老家过年，
我感觉现在这个状态挺好的，
又没有结婚证，
然后他每个月又给2万块钱的抚养费，
彼此之间没有结婚证，
就没有太多的约束，
我就多说一句啊，
你别怪我操心，
或者怪我嘴巴，
因为我跟你有相同的焦虑，
我理解你，
因为我时常也会跟我的对象去聊，
假设我要是走在前面啊，
我家里面这些人，
你怎么对待孩子怎么怎么样，
你将来怎么怎么样，
我会不会管你，
我也会有这样的焦虑，
所以我特别能理。
我多说一句啊，
就是我们要做到了预防所有的风险，
比如说假设开车的话，
那第一时间是要落锁，
要看一下后座有没有人，
尽量不要去有没有人的地方，
远离那些一切有可能的风险啊。
与此同时的话，
就是内心不断的强化，
我跟你分享我的心法好不好，
我内心就不断的在强化，
我爷爷我奶奶在地底下，
他们肯定会保佑我的，
为啥呢？
只有保佑我，
他们的孩子才有好日子过，
我们家只要是的亲戚都得保佑我，
为什么呢？
我对他们家的孩子也不错啊，
对他们亲戚各方面都做的挺到位。
再有一个是什么呢？
我感觉我这辈子也没做过什么伤天害理的事儿，
也没做过什么坑蒙拐骗的事儿，
所以我哎哟，
就应该平平安安活到老，
就是我给自己的心理暗示，
再有一个就是不管怎么样，
就是我拿到这个剧本的话，
只要我能平平安安活到老，
就没有人敢欺负我的孩子，
无论面对什么样的困难，
无论面对什么样的这个风险，
无论面对什么样的坎坷，
我一定能挺过去。
就这3个心法啊，
好，
可能是丹丹，
我能理解这个姐妹，
她的这种担忧就让她焦虑，
会看到一个新闻说一个人去世了之后，
她可能名下本来有房，
本来有车，
本来有存款，
但是没有人知道密码，
也没有人能够帮他去签字，
去动用。
这些财产去救他的命，
你们看过那个新闻吗？
看过的扣1我看到的时候我也会有这种感触，
其实我跟我对象我俩也会聊这些话题，
就是如果他走在前面了，
我要怎么安排这些事儿，
他名下的钱要怎么安排，
我俩聊的透透的，
我走在前面了，
我名下的这些钱怎么安排，
我俩也聊得透透的啊，
我俩还打算回头在银行是不是能开一个共管账户，
不知道现在哪些银行能开啊，
这样的话就是不管我走在前头还是他走在前头，
谁动用钱都很方便。
记得点赞关注哦。